this episode brought to you by gray
block pizza gray block pizza at 1811
Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles consider
gray block today's episode features a
young lady that I met through a friend
with a mutual friend and she's uh she's
I mean she's a bad beauty of basketball
if you ask me you know and I'm honest I
always had maybe a mild little crush on
her if I'm being 100% transparent and I
am I'm just so happy to have her here
today she's smart and she's eloquent and
she's she's extremely charming she is
the owner of the Los Angeles Lakers miss
Jeanne fuss
[Music]
you're the first female that we've had
and that's not a comedian I think I know
that's true can you hear the lovely
Jeannie bus is here thank you for coming
thanks for having me yeah and we were
talking cuz you and I have a mutual
friend dr. Wilker B and we were talking
about you you're gonna you're doing
stand-up comedy I'm taking a class
because I I'm asked to speak a lot and
I'm painfully shy and so I thought if I
could be a little bit more funny then
maybe it wouldn't be so painful for me
Wow so I I'm taking a class it's for you
know it's called pretty funny women hmm
and so it's women only and then Laurie
Kilmartin who runs that know who is that
Lisa sunset yes and so I'm looking
forward to that and it's you know to
challenge myself in tonight's the first
class tonight's the first class so I had
to prepare you know kind of an opening
where she talked about you know like
when you when you get up in front of an
audience you try to connect with them
right right and so she said if you have
something outstanding about you like a
funny voice or you're really tall or
something you know maybe talk about that
in your opening just so then because
people are watching you up on stage they
don't know what who you are they're just
immediately about what they say right
and so like and so I kind of wrote my
opening around something that a friend
of mine said about me and I and I took
that and that's gonna kind of be my
comedy let's start look I want to start
right there then so let you have the
opening I can't I mean I can give it to
you okay give it to me a little bit if
you feel comfortable okay so so you know
I get up on stage and I say you know you
know it's great to be here tonight and
you know I this new for me I'm learning
how to do it and you know I was kind of
told that you kind of introduce yourself
to the
audience and you know maybe something
about you and and and so I asked one of
my girlfriends when you if if you saw me
standing up in front of an audience and
you didn't know me mm-hmm what would you
think and she said I would think Barbie
and and I'm thinking Oh Barbie okay I
can I can kind of get that a little bit
okay and she goes mom Barbie's mom oh my
gosh
wait a minute like let's hope the
Corvette's insured kind of thing
Barbie's mom who's Barbies mom have we
ever talked about Barbies mom we don't
know we don't know who it was
that's so true who was his Sondra what's
the mother's name Diane right is it like
it's is was she like a science
experiment attached to like and and you
know did Ken miss out on like a
mother-daughter trio and and I thought
about like you know every time you know
Ken and Barbie got married I never
invited mom yeah mom wasn't there like I
think it's ruined a generation of
woman's relationship with their mom
because Barbie do you have one you
didn't need one Yeah right so and then
of course that leads us to the you know
well then who's Barbie's dad Wow well we
know she had a Corvette in a dream house
so maybe it's almost ready I didn't see
that coming so that's kind of the first
built into the joke perfect the first
thing I've ever oh wow it's good no I
love hearing you talk about that and the
other night whenever whenever I saw you
whenever we you know we're at our we
have a mutual friend and we've met
before I saw you a few times over the
years and then we sat together at their
wedding or on the same table yeah but uh
but you started talking about stand-up
comedy when we're talking about and I
was like wow I said Jeannie is just
she's so charming you know
I thought you were just a beautiful lady
I thought you were just extremely
charming I was like I would laugh I want
to know more about like her trying to
make people laugh and I took a class you
know when I got understandable a lot of
people know I took a class and I didn't
do it for about two years but I did take
a class
and it was helpful and was a lot of fun
and you get to perform at the end mm-hmm
so you guys will have a date probably in
a couple of months where you'll be doing
stand-up comedy probably are you taking
a friend with you to the class or no no
no this I have to I have to push myself
and challenge myself and and you know
get myself out of the zone of comfort
and you know it says this is what I
decided to do yeah and I really
appreciate you know the people that I've
spoken to that are in the comedy
business have been so nice and
supportive and so I really I kind of
cornered you at the the fourth of July
barbecue and picked your brain and and
you know how generous you are with your
advice and and support appreciate that
yeah I want a hard look I would love to
help you punch up any jokes I told you I
want to come to one of these functions
because you're like because you have to
speak at a lot of functions I guess and
now are they women's functions are they
leadership functions like and just a
premise oh so just so anybody's clear
and I'm not even sure are you are part
of the partnership that owns the the
Lakers or or a chairperson what is it
yeah you know it's it's the Lakers have
been in my family since 1980 and you
know it my father bought the team I was
17 years old and I have worked in the
family business in different aspects but
really what my father intended was he
wanted the team to stay in the family
and he passed away five years ago
and through very conscientious effort on
his part he you know he left the team in
a trust that would be controlled or
benefit that his children his six
children and so he he had to designate
who the person ultimately in charge was
because the NBA threw league rules only
will recognize one owner one voice Wow
that is the the sole decision maker
for the franchise and so that's the
position that I have and what some
people have heard about is you know a a
year ago I had to remove my brother who
was running our basketball operation at
the time okay and it was kind of an
unusual circumstance because I had to
use the authority that was given to me
by my father to to do that and and and
the preoptic right and people who are in
family businesses can understand how
difficult that is but it was something
that was really important to my father
to keep the team in the family and I
couldn't see any progress as to how the
basketball side was run and so I brought
Magic Johnson in to run the operation
and I think he's done a good job in the
last 16 17 months and his magic is
pretty fascinating he must be just so
charming huh is it just immediate charm
what is it about him you know what it is
it's very interesting because he you
know people kind of compare him with
another Laker great Kobe Bryant and both
equally successful in terms of winning
championships each have won five but
magic had this big smile on his face
yeah the charisma always he smiled about
HIV pretty much it seems like you know
you know he smiled as well he's he is he
is Ali a natural leader with that kind
of charisma but now that I've I'm with
him in the in the board room and hearing
him make strategy as to how we're
putting our team together he will
continue to smile as he talks about
dissecting the other teams in the league
cutting them apart he is he will he will
make you feel good but he will be like
it was a win yes and now do you think
that he always had this because I'm a
magic fan I don't think I'm a I don't
think you could find I never thought
about this I don't think you could find
a person in the world that's probably
not a fan of Magic Johnson
I'm saying like there's just something
about him you almost I mean you remember
what team he played for the Lakers but
you just there's something about him
that makes you feel good well he he's a
worldwide figure and certainly Muhammad
Ali was you know beloved and and stood
really for for so much in this world and
I would say that Magic has that same
kind of of persona and he's revered all
around the world it's fascinating and
serginho but his business acumen is that
something that he's learned he he is he
he's like you know he wanted to learn
everything even as starring for the
Lakers and winning championships he was
wanting to know more about business and
he was like a sponge he would go and he
would pick the brains of all the the
smart people that he would meet and most
importantly my father and so when he and
I are together you know working
strategizing we speak the same language
because we were basically raised by the
same man
you know I my dad bought the team when I
was 17 magic came that same year at age
so we're basically the same age and we
learned at the you know the hand of one
of the greatest owners ever most
winningest owners dr. Jerry bass my
father yeah what's something that you
miss about your father you know he used
to I was thinking about this so this is
the first thing on my mind he used to
sing there's a song called I dream of
Jeanie with the light brown hair he's
dissing that to me all the time and you
know nobody's ever nobody sings that
song anymore nobody really even knows
about that song but that was you know
that was his special song for me I gotta
move my purse sorry
oh nice so yeah so that was like a sweet
thing you guys had he would sing that
sometimes yeah what was something like
he would do like even like a physical
affection like I remember like my father
was 70 when I was born my dad was very
old and
I remember like I didn't have like a lot
of moments with him but I remember like
sometimes my dad would and my mom never
let him sleep in the bed so he would
just be out and about basically just
wandering around the house all night you
know and he's sitting a chair and lay on
the couch or something and so sometimes
I come in and like I'd you know sneaking
in a kitchen to get some milk or
something and he'd be over sitting in a
chair and he'd like come over here and I
wouldn't know he'd even be over this
being the dark kind of and I'd go over
and he would just kind of like he would
like kind of put his arm like on me or
something and then his breath would kind
of smell like beer like you hit a couple
beers and we just spent so few moments
together but it's one of the moments I
remember the bet it was like for me that
was like a third of our relationship was
me like you know anything else about
your dad that was just kind of like a
special thing you guys would do or a
special moment that you remember for
even from any point in your life why you
know going back to your dad I love
hearing the story about I didn't realize
not only was your dad an older father
but you guys he had a bunch of kids you
guys right like so you had simply very
then yeah you will you had like siblings
so like you know wasn't just like you by
yourself oh yeah there were four was
running around I remember my mom she
would get mad then my dad wouldn't spank
us of course he's 76 years old and you
know I'm saying he doesn't really have
the physical acumen to be out there
swinging paddles so she would make him
chase us around the house right which is
so easy to get away from a 76 year old
alarmingly so what we would do is we
would go under the bed and then my dad
would like get a belt and he would like
get down to the floor would take him 30
seconds to get down on the floor we'd be
under the bed like screaming like we
were scared but dying laughing and then
he would like stroll the belt under the
bed like try to swing it at us and we
would scream as if we'd been hit even
though we had not we were literally
covering our mouth like just with
laughter you know we had to pretend like
we were getting spanked so my mom in the
next room would be like oh they're
getting spanked and then she would give
him cut him some slack you know it was
yeah and it was sweet it was like fun
you know we would
him and my brother would always tell me
dad's dead you know and he would come in
the room and dad was just taking a nap
but like there was like a 50/50 chance
every time you know so you go in there
just see if dad's dead that was like a
game we played like just ridiculous kind
of growing up with an older dad was
there did you guys ever do anything
together like did you guys ever just do
some fun stuff that was just you and him
because with six kids it's probably hard
to get time with just y'all - yeah well
I you know when when I was growing up it
was just the four of us kids and then he
had two more kids later in life but you
know one story that I I'll share with
you is my dad had a big sweet tooth
loved candy so on Halloween
we would get dressed up and we'd go
trick-or-treating and then you know we'd
come back and he'd want to see all our
candy all the kids candy so everybody
had to put the candy so he go okay where
did you get this Hershey bar you know
cuz it'd be like the full-size Hershey
bar it was okay you're gonna you're
gonna change costumes and you're going
back to that house to get another one
and and so he he he would negotiate with
us and he'd he told us there was this
rule that like okay you have to give dad
half your candy what you know I'm like
okay fifty-fifty that seems fair but
then a couple I guess the years went by
I went wait a minute you're getting half
of four kids candy and 200 percent of
candy yeah and I it like I'm thinking
I'm being fair it's 50/50 but he's
getting that time score he says yeah
he'll always always always got the best
end of a deal right
did he have other large aspirations that
people didn't even know about that only
you guys knew about kind of in the home
like and not to call him out or judging
anything look I think it's you know I
think it's beautiful for us to like talk
about our parents and like think about
things that they wanted to do and stuff
like that you know I think you know a
father/daughter relationship or any
parent-child relationship is you know
it's special but was so when you were
young did he have an aspiration to own a
team he always loved sports it really
his goal was to have enough money to
afford season tickets to go the Dodgers
like that would have been success in his
eyes and he achieved it it's kind of an
yeah I mean he you know he got his PhD
at the age of 23 he was a physical
chemist and worked for you know the
aerospace companies working on rocket
ship fuel and he really wanted to have
kids and he just he couldn't afford you
know the on his salary thinking about
the family that he wanted to build and
so he decided to save a little money and
buy an apartment building and then he
would be able to take that money and
invest it and as he met some of his
fellow co-workers they were all like
well what we want to invest too so
slowly but surely they built this real
estate empire and it was like the you
know late 60s early 70s in Southern
California and he ended up you know his
mathematical mind he just he he built
most of the apartment buildings that you
see in San Monica today and any of them
that are named after monopoly property
that's what he would name the different
buildings so there is a a waterworks a
Remora gardens or not I'd pretty sure
there's a Marvin gardens in the st.
James Place and and all those so you
know he he turned that into a fortune
and he bought a team a team in world
TeamTennis
which that was back in the mid to late
70s what we talked about this and it
didn't pan out it was like a traveling
tennis right competition or something
right yeah it just it didn't it didn't
work but it the last year of the team
Chris Evert played on the team and
strings or some lay strings and they
played at the Forum and he noticed that
at that time jack kent cooke owned the
lakers and the kings and he never went
to any games and so he did some research
and Cooke was going through a divorce at
the time and moved to
vada so that he could be a Nevada
resident and anyway save money on taxes
or no yeah we're on the divorce and so
he started working on him to buy the
Lakers and the Kings in the forum and
that it was a two-year process and he
was able to do it so he he really always
loved sports he chose to get his PhD
from USC because of the football team he
thought they were the best team and you
know he he just you know loved all kinds
of sports but it's cool he really wanted
the Lakers to be something Los Angeles
could be proud of was it was he such a
bit because there's one thing I noticed
about business even as his my own life
gets busier is that it takes up a lot of
time you know and it takes up a lot of
responsibility and you have to you know
start to be efficient and organized and
was it too was he too busy like my
mother was a hard worker right but we
were basically raised about my mother
you know and and she still works to this
day and so I never even got to really
spend that much time with either my
parents really my dad was too old too my
mother had to work all the time and so
was he too busy was it hard to have a
connection sometimes just because a
business it's busy that that's why that
you know sports was the way we connected
as a family and so having that time
together to to go to the horse races or
go to a Dodger game or go to a USC track
meet or whatever it was that's what we
did as a family and so I guess that that
kind of stays with me knowing how
important the Lakers are to the
community and to you know families
because I've I can't tell you how many
letters I've had from you know a
grandmother who says it's the only thing
she can talk to with her 15 year old
grandson is the Lakers and and how you
know everybody makes time to be together
to turn on a game and and watch
especially in the playoffs but we
haven't been in the playoffs in five
years so hopefully this year you deliver
on that was it hard to come up but was
it kind of hard to have
your own identity you think growing up
like in that environment once you guys
had the Lakers at 17 like or did you
just kind of grow in because I could
imagine like if my family owned
something that was you know so big that
had such a life of its own such an
umbrella would it be hard would I be
scared that I had never kind of known if
it was something else I wanted to get
into do you have any thoughts like that
yeah I mean I always knew I wanted to be
in the family business but at the time
when I was growing up it was real estate
development so I always thought I would
be in real estate but really my
motivation was always about growing a
business with my family right no matter
whatever it was and I didn't always work
for the Lakers when my dad bought the
team he also bought the forum and when
you own an arena and you have a hockey
team and a basketball team that's about
a hundred nights a year well there's you
know two hundred and fifty other nights
a year that you need something going on
in a building well my dad put me in
charge of he called it orphan sports
like all the sports that nobody really
knew what to do so I had the stress you
know volleyball had tennis I had what
something that came that we never even
did that roller hockey really yeah and I
thought and wouldn't know my dad says I
just bought you a team in roller hockey
I'm like oh I I had no idea what this
was going to be this is the early 90s
and I thought I was gonna have to go
down to the beach and get inline skaters
yeah that's what I'm thinking as you're
saying that and like teach them how to
play hockey but as it turns out it was
the other way around it was hockey
players wanted to play roller hockey and
with the new equipment everything was
evolving so quickly that they've the
hockey players learned how to make a
hockey stop on inline skates
oh wow which was like to do the twist
and they yeah and stop on a dime and so
that the sport took off and all the kids
were playing it and they were building
indoor rinks
and even to the point where David Stern
who was the Commissioner of the NBA
called me and he said what are you guys
doing that these kids and rollerblades
are taking over our basketball courts
you know like he he saw this as a
movement and you know the first year we
had 12 teams by the second year we had
doubled in size there's 24 teams we had
owners who owned NHL teams buying roller
hockey teams and the reason was that it
was it literally it it would play during
the summertime when arenas our dad
anybody can play you don't have ice
right you don't have ice which is really
expensive and if you have Dasher boards
at your arena you can play it so it was
the cheapest event to put on in the
summertime hockey players needed
something to do to earn money especially
the minor-league ones and stay in shape
and it just it was like a boom but of
course as every minor league can tell
you you you have owners who are over
leveraged don't know what they're doing
they own like a car dealership and they
go I can own a sports team so they get
into sports and they don't know what
they're doing
lose a ton of money and we just we
couldn't sustain ourselves so we it
folded after eight years and I was so
disappointed because I really thought
this was going to be the sport you know
that Americans could dominate in hockey
like the best players finally a chance
to go against Canada right right and so
treat hockey well anything else like
what was it with her I'm trying to think
of a crazy sport like I remember being
in love when I was younger with the
roller derby
yeah roller Derby's cool with that come
over there over to the forum it seems
like it's too small just like how does
the how does roller derby like how how
is it scored like how does it like is it
really a team like I thought was like
the strong everybody everybody seemed
like a lesbian I figure if there's a
male or female on there they everybody
had the same sort of like everybody look
like bebop or Rocksteady from the Ninja
Tara
as to like kind of guys but yeah I don't
know there's no basket right I mean is
it gonna ever be an Olympic sport you
know like I loved it though it's it was
yeah it was it's still going on they're
still like roller derby in places yeah I
loved it so you guys have you guys so
how about this your fears like going up
with the stand-up comedy so your fears
obviously you have some fear that people
are gonna think since your Genie bus
because your name right but you're uh to
me it doesn't seem like you like ride on
your net like you seem separate from
your name a little bit to me you know
yeah I just because your name is a big
thing sometimes especially in LA you
know that the person sometimes can be
set can be a different I'm just I guess
I'm a person that has to know you know I
have to I didn't start at the top like I
had to I couldn't be at the top if I
didn't know how everything else worked
right so I guess I'm I'm a person who is
curious and likes to you know how know
how everything operates and now I'm
getting to do stand-up comedy
are you I don't think that people are
gonna judge you are you worried about
that a little bit I mean yeah you know
cuz I don't think I'm funny but I really
appreciate people who are funny so so I
guess it's it's like out of respect that
I'm gonna try yeah but I really defer to
really talented people but you're I
think you're so charming that they're
gonna like you so that is half of it a
lot of it is just as long as they like
you they'll listen to the set they're
like oh yeah listen to this person I'm
enjoying myself
yeah do you have any other kind of
topics are realms you're gonna talk
about
yeah like cuz now I'm single hmm and so
I do theater together worked at a car
dealership you tell me that no I was
actually a cellular company oh yeah
that's awesome a cellular phone guy yeah
and and and so yeah that was made me
want to dust off my t-mobile Sidekick
when I heard this
man I'm gonna do huh well it's a you
know it's it's like I was in a long-term
relationship with Phil Jackson and you
know that's been over now for two years
and do you think that would end I didn't
think it was gonna add no and you know
in in and so we were together since you
know 1999 and so it was really before
like smartphones and dating apps and all
that so I'm like really behind on how to
get out there so like I was at a my
cellular company getting a new phone
literally trying to get back out there
and and so well I know I mean I'm just
getting together you're trying to get
yeah you're trying to get completely
innocent and so so then you know the guy
that was helping me he gave me his card
and he said if you have any problems
just you know text me so black problems
even not having him in your life it
seems like but when I got by the time I
got home you know he sent me a text and
how's the phone every minute oh yeah of
course he has my number and so then he
then he asked me to dinner and you know
I where did he take you
well I this is all by tax like right now
so like everything young people do is by
tax like okay and so okay I gotta get
used to that and so and you know with
texting you just don't really know how I
mean I it's it's awkward for me so he's
you know he's he I said well do you know
how old I am you know cuz he's you know
in his 20s and he goes yeah I know how
old you are and you're hot or whatever
I'm like okay that's good answer I said
wait do you have a girlfriend he's like
no I don't have a girlfriend
and I'm like you know are you married
just making sure yeah and he's like no
no and so I'm like you know I really I
think this is this isn't a good idea and
he's he's like I'm not taking no for an
answer so I says you respect yeah I
respected that because you know he he he
was relentless so I'm like I'm gonna
have to like I'm gonna have to have
dinner with them and tell them why I
can't date I'm face to face cuz the
texting isn't working I like that
so I least have dinner with me and tell
me why you don't want to write elective
I just felt like I had to explain to him
this difference is like it's not that's
a great idea of a woman rejects me in
the future BEC look at least have dinner
with me and tell me why you don't want
to spend time with me it's really a
great idea yeah so I so we made it plans
to have dinner and so then the next day
he texted me and he said like you know
hey I'm really sorry you know can we
change can we reschedule our dinner
because I forgot it's my boys birthday
and you know I can't miss it and I'm
like oh my god I didn't ask him if he
has any kids oh wow
and so I'm like oh back away back away I
don't need any like drama and Jerry Buss
is Jerry Springer you know the woman
who's the mother of the kid is gonna
take me on my wives are flashing through
your head a bit so I like I texted him
and I figured okay well yeah you know
let's just wait till after the holidays
and you know we'll get together you
should absolutely be there for your
son's birthday and then he texts me back
and he goes what makes you think I have
a son well he said I have it's my boys
birthday oh he's just saying his boys
it's my boys birthday like by text I'm
going to his boy his boy his son that's
exchange right so if he sends eggplant
emojis you think he's thinking about
vegetables like what do you like at this
point I wonder what you like I can't
even imagine how some of the exchange
rate is lost it's just it's hard to meet
people so that I figured in my comedy
that that would be a lot of it because
everybody's got the same problem you
know like finding a relationship how to
date you know just all the different
things that so it's true how old you are
I like it no I my angle I like it I
think it's cool it's exciting yeah yeah
I hope you really could do it I want to
come and watch well I I'm thinking now
of dating my stalker
you are yeah you have one it's not the
same guy is it yeah well yeah no not
that guy not the cellular phone guy no
it's like you know and and you know at
least I'll know where he is all the time
right
at least I'll be right outside with you
in the garden sorry like we have like
the same taste in underwear mine I like
this and enjoys it and I'm sorry if I've
been making you feel uncomfortable when
I've been stalking I uh that's
interesting is it after you got out of a
relationship so Phil Jackson's a coach
right yeah he's a coach yes were there
other coaches that hit you up I'm sure
there's got to be some low-key coaches
out there no I don't think I want to get
Malte than other coach yeah
or their lives have you noticed a change
in the value of a coach to a team over
the years like did a coach used to have
more power and prowess and be looked up
to differently it's very that's a very
interesting question because you know
you you have kind of like a power
struggle between say the front office
who are in charge of getting players to
be on the team for the coach who has to
coach them and you know make the team
successful so if if the front office
doesn't want the coach to succeed it's
really easy to give him players that
don't fit his system really that can
happen a lot of oh yeah it does happen
and that's why San Antonio isn't
interesting because of the success that
they've had and you have a coach who's
very vocal in terms of the player
personnel right so he really gets the
players that he wants on his team and
and of course he's the longest tenured
girl that's right now but so is
having issues with this front office
right now no no not at all it's just
it's just it's how you're set up as a
team and you know making sure like like
one of the the things that I wasn't
happy about with our team in the last
few years is that we had a really good
coach by the name of Mike Brown who's a
defensive minded coach and so the
Cavaliers for a long time didn't he yes
he did
and and now he's with Golden State
working with Steve Kerr but he was our
head coach and you know that's fine a
defensive minded coach then the the
front office got Steve Nash and Steve
Nash is also is like a very offensive
guy so his style didn't fit when Mike
Brown wanted to do so then Mike Brown
got replaced with Mike D'Antoni who is
you know another great coach he's in
Houston now and but he's a very
offensive minded coach and so when you
when you change coaches that quickly
your roster can't you know can't change
as quickly right and so players that
that we had like a Dwight Howard really
wasn't going to fit into what a coach
D'Antoni
style of play that he would want to play
so it's it's really just like you have
to as an organization you have to decide
who you want to be as a basketball team
the style of play that you're going to
play and once you decide that then every
decision has to go back to that event
overlying premise of like who we are so
every player you draft the players you
draft for the players that you you know
trade away you know you you've got to it
has to be a cohesive every decision over
the top right for that top piece now do
you know but do you feel like there's
difference like do coaches still have as
much control over teams these two or is
it more it seems like we're in such this
me time where everybody you know is
there as much power for a coach now
you know I yeah there are very powerful
coaches in the league and you know those
are the ones who have success and and
when you're a coach you have to be
stubborn and you have to believe in what
you're doing and if you know if
ownership and the front office don't
agree you have to stand for your
principles and you'll probably get fired
but that's just that's why coaches get
hired and fired that the probably more
often than front office people have you
had some crazy experiences you had any
experiences where like I'm sure some
coaches tried to woo you or do something
wild for the organization to get that
job like was there for anything like
that that's interesting
no I I think you know I I think coaches
you know kind of I guess the laker job
is a great job but we have a coach that
I can see being our coach for a long
time to come Luke Walton who you know
has you know really has a really great
ability to connect with players you know
throughout their career he works well
with the young players he works well
with the students and he's he is a
winner and he is a great motivator and I
think he's he's somebody like I said
that I think will be successful with
going forward when you guys have
exceeded LeBron James in now and so
that's that's so wild it's such a huge
it's huge on so many levels was there
any talk of Kobe coming back to play
with him
Kobe knows that anytime he wants to come
and do anything for the organization
he's more than welcome he he was
somebody that I leaned on in the last
couple years in terms of you know just
picking his brain he might be one of the
best strategists I've ever spoken to yes
and you know his ability to dissect to
the smallest detail but also see the
bigger picture
and take take the camera back and really
take in the whole situation you know he
is he's a valuable resource to me and
somebody that is someone I admire
respect both on and off the court he's a
hard worker he's a hard worker yeah yeah
maybe the hardest you think he's one of
the hardest-working players that ever
played for the Lakers
yeah I mean you know when you have a guy
that is you know a veteran with that
kind of success being the first one to
practice every day yeah that sets the
bar you know everybody else how can the
best player on the team be here before
you
you got to work harder I mean he he just
brought that kind of element to the team
did it seem like this is a regular fan
it seemed like he's like at the end it
just seemed like there was like he like
he took so much of them are like the
money in the business there was no money
for anybody else you know that that's
not fair to look at it that way that you
know and that's not an election that's
an unknowable fan saying and then I'm
happy to have the opportunity to kind of
fill in you know so you see the whole
picture but yes it's you know in the NBA
we have a salary cap which everybody
hears about it but we also have a salary
floor like there's a minimum amount you
have to spend and it's not that big of a
difference between so somebody's gonna
get the money right
and so really Kobe for the the the
amount of weight on the team that he
pulled right he deserved that money
right so I have no problem with that
would you be shocked if could if Kobe
came back to play with LeBron I mean I
think his wife would you know his wife
Aisha she would be mad at me but but you
know it's like you know Kobe has to do
what's in Kobe's journey you know and I
I couldn't twist his arm to do it but he
if he wanted to I would make sure it
happened you know it's it's really up to
him and and you know we retired both his
numbers last year in a ceremony that was
difficult for me because he's somebody
that I I don't think I can ever
completely show my gratitude really -
yeah I mean he really wanted the you
know the biggest influences on my life
and you know what he means to the Lakers
and you know I kind of you know it was
hard for him he didn't want to he didn't
want to go through that kind of ceremony
he never really liked that kind of
attention he loved playing basketball he
loved winning basketball games but doing
all the other stuff was you know that's
just not his style Wow
do you uh do you feel like if there was
another job that Kobe got into what
would it be outside of sports well you
know he he has an oscar-winning film
producer now after his his movie his
short film was nominated he won in that
category and so I see him as a
storyteller as a creative person who can
you know bring things to life because he
the way he could break down detail and
and kind of absorb what was happening
and I mean you know there are stories
about how he would study you know
cheetahs and how cheetahs would you know
move stalk their prey and how they would
move and how they use their tail as
balance and you know I mean he just it's
like that's a an intricate mind that you
know can capture and and you know
express and explain things in an
interesting way
do you was it did you feel like like
royalty you must have all I mean since
you were 17 you did you I mean it must
have been interesting growing up like in
like a long this just this this
basketball timeline that just came in
your life this whole sports timeline how
do you how do you manage like dealing
with ego and stuff like that and staying
that sort of thing because a lot of
people deal with that I mean ego is
really can be the downfall of so many
people you know and it's amazing that
the downfall of so many great things
happening outside of us is inside of us
um but I mean you know you know is
sometimes that is what what makes a
great athlete may not make a great
husband hmm
you know the ability to focus and be
driven and be of single mind competition
you know may mean that he's not a good
partner for his spouse or girlfriend or
whatever so I I mean I'm not gonna say
that you have to be a completely
well-balanced person because you
probably wouldn't be the number one
tennis player in the world if you you
know went to everybody's birthday and
showed up at graduations of all your
horizons right so I know a really good
point it comes with a you know you know
it's its choice it's sacrifice and you
know I believe that that you know in the
NBA for example we have you know 450 of
the best basketball players in the world
and they have given up a lot to be to be
that and and and that's why for me I
always tried to embrace the families the
parents the the spouses the children of
our players because they're the ones who
sacrificed the most well to allow you
know they're there
yeah they're their loved one to be you
know good race yeah yeah yeah it's
amazing what cost there is that people
don't realize that amazing the other
side of the teeter-totter that people
that you don't see right you know you
don't see like the you know the FaceTime
calls with the family that kind of stuff
that's just and that that's well getting
up at five o'clock in the morning and
and working out and and you know not
ever missing you know a practice or a
game or getting back on an airplane
after you know it double overtime
you know it's it's your ego has to be
pretty strong because you you know you
keep pushing yourself keep pushing
yourself to the to the point you know of
where most people just say I'm out yeah
so much for me I want to stay home
tonight do you what were some of your
favorite years like that you had over
the years when you thought that the MBA
was just I mean obviously it's at a
great level right now it's exciting
was it a blast like when was it a blast
well the 80s was great and you know
we're working on a docu-series about the
show time that 80's era Showtime magic
and who else and Kareem those guys James
Worthy yeah I loved worthy everybody
loved him huh yeah I saw him one time
the first the only game I ever went to
for the Lakers was in Kobe scored 81
points yeah that's the only game I've
ever been to in my whole life and I
shared like a bowl of peanuts and like
some fancy Club Lounge for players only
I think and then I got a picture of
Chris with next to Chris Rock by the
bathroom and he was not happy about it
and I made his wife take it I asked his
wife to take it and make her do anything
this is anomie to that that game that 81
point game I think I always point out to
people that the Lakers were down at
halftime by 20 points oh wow and that
Kobe had to score 81 points in order for
us to win that game it was it wasn't
just a blowout game where he was messing
around like can I make this shot I mean
he single-handedly won that game brought
us back and made us win that game that's
the tiger honor right yep Toronto and
Jalen Rose still talks about I bet we're
just in shock just a couple weeks before
that he scored 63 against Dallas in
three quarters and they sat him for the
whole fourth quarter and then he could
have he could have did it then but they
didn't need it exactly I got in a fight
with self that night because I said
why'd you take him out he had he could
have gotten you know and he said because
we were gonna win the game that's
ridiculous you don't you don't risk your
player
you know when you're you know because
phil was always about winning the gabe
not about in devote individual
achievements right he thought about more
about the win right but that eighty
one-point game it was he had to keep
kobe in every minute because they needed
the win exactly uh does uh when do you
still communicate with phil you guys oh
yeah we're still close he's he's had
such an influence on me and what's he
like what's some that people don't know
about i mean what we see is as a regular
consumer i consider myself a basic adult
male and so you know it seemed like he's
tall is it hard to love her that's tall
that seems hard i feel he is tall he
stands out wherever he goes but he he
really taught me the other side of the
gate i knew the business side but i
really understood the you know the wear
and tear on the players what he was
trying to create with his team like we
got in a fight because he made the
players practice on thanksgiving and i
said come on can't you give them one day
off so that they can be at home with
their families and he said first of all
he goes their home in plenty of time to
have Thanksgiving dinner with their
families he said I bring them in to
practice because they have to they have
to learn that this team is their family
and that they need to be together on
holidays - Wow and so he really taught
me that aspect of of you know you've got
to instill in these players that they
have each other's back and that they
will sacrifice you know everything for
each other and that that's really what
makes a strong team and and really in in
basketball more than any other sport you
you if you keep your core players
together you can have a dynasty like
what we're seeing in Golden State right
now they have this core group of guys
that are together and they might switch
out a couple players here and there but
that that group is they are devoted to
each other they love each other and they
will go you know yeah they want to be in
the trenches with each other what was
the arm was
what was something else or like what was
something was it was it just time I mean
that's a long relationship you guys had
from 99 yeah you know it just you know
he took a job in New York running the
New York Knicks and you know we knew
that was going to be a challenge for us
to be a part and it just things just
didn't go the right way and and our
relationship fell apart just by
long-distance which happens to many many
people so you know it's a tough business
to be in because it's so demanding and
it worked while we were working with the
same team but once we were on opposite
coasts it was just too difficult to
overcome and was it the best
relationship that you've ever had you
think definitely the most influential on
my life but we never got married I
wanted to get married early on he
finally proposed after 12 years and then
took the job in New York and so we never
did get married but I loved him he like
I said he's had such an influence on me
and and and taking on the game in a
holistic approach you know the whole the
whole team the whole person the the
entire the player is the organism of you
know of what he loves to coach he loves
it he loves it and he's good at it and
you know when you're talking asking me
what like the worst time of my career
was was probably in the 90s because the
Chicago Bulls dominated the entire
league and it just it was just so
frustrating because magic had to retire
in 1991 because of the HIV diagnosis and
you know so we we lost magic should've
let him play in a suit that guy was good
enough to play you know and didn't they
try for a season or two yeah he did kind
of come back but you know he so they
made him retire so that was and that
that would have been the piece that
maybe could I had you guys contend
exactly so he retired too soon we
weren't ready for that so the
organization went through five or six
years of you know just a drow only
missed the players playoffs once in that
year yeah and then Shaquille O'Neal came
in 1996 as well as a rookie but I named
a Kobe Bryant changed things and that
changed things for something then
Michael Jordan retired chasing for the
whole league how great I mean how great
was Michael Jordan was it just something
different to why yeah you know I'd ask
Phil like you know what how is how is
Michael different than Kobe different
than LeBron and you know all different
players you know I mean he's never
coached LeBron but he would talk about
LeBrons just physical power right that
there is no stopping him you know like
yeah it almost seems like a cheat like a
cheat code and then one of those games
it's like oh you got a special code his
shoulders like human hands I mean I and
you know he's he's come into practice a
couple times and I've you know I never
really paid attention to LeBron I mean I
watch games on TV but you know they'd
come here once a year you know and and
so watching him and his footwork and his
work just what he what he does isn't
just in practice that man is he is
really phenomenal I I'm so excited for
Laker fans that he's on our team and
that we get to watch this this just
great player and the prime of his career
you know come and play for us can you
even answer this question that like that
Michael you think was maybe the best
player ever Michael definitely you know
here's the thing is like you know you
get in these debates and arguments and
Michael won six championships never lost
in a final if he was in a final he won
right so amazing isn't that amazing you
know magic lost I think to finals no he
lost four or five magic was in nine
finals and won five you know cuz Larry
Bird you know yeah feat Nez
and then Kobe was in seven finals and
won five so I don't know
does that make Michael better because he
won six because he was undefeatable
feeling like though like the vibe like
what I mean
cuz you got to see you got to see some
of this you know I mean I know you were
you know you were diff you know at
different ages when these things have
occurred but like I mean their head I
mean that Michael fever was just it was
something different was like Elvis when
he came to town like tickets the ticket
brokers it was it was like the Beatles
you know at the height of their
popularity screaming fans just wanting
to to see him yeah like he he was like
nothing I've ever seen in terms of his
stardom and stardom was different than
and I was just thinking about this
yesterday that Fame was different then
it was like it's not the same now like
everybody can be a little bit famous
I was actually this guy Gary Vaynerchuk
you know that is Gary Vee or whatever
he's like a fancy speaker I'm like a
business oh yeah I think that guy so he
I was working at this conference with
him this weekend and he was talking
about how like in the past everybody be
fent
famous for 15 minutes of fame but now
everybody's famous to 15 people that's
kind of like it was just some equation
that he made you know but it's like yeah
everybody's like a little bit famous now
it seems like famous different so
Michael had it at a time when it was
that was almost like the height of fame
in some ways just at that moment it was
before like social media taken over and
before everybody had like a way to get
their picture and their head shot out
there it was like it had to be
unprecedented yeah I mean I think Spike
Lee helped that with you know kind of
you know directing those Nike
commercials the shoes it's got to be the
shoes than anything since then nobody's
had more success just by buying Knicks
tickets and wearing huge sunglasses and
Spike Lee that guy I like spike and and
you know and and so now Michael Jordan
is the owner of the Charlotte Hornets
and so now I've gotten to know him as
you know another governor of a team in
the boardroom and he is brilliant
and he is well-spoken
and thoughtful and you know now he's one
of my favorite people but really in the
90s I was no no not that not a chance
oh I drove me when people would call me
and say can I can you help me get
tickets to see Michael Jordan I'm like
hello you're calling were the Lakers if
you call me and say just pretend you he
just he just made people go cuckoo yeah
and and you know and he did thrill he
could definitely play the game but now
you know he's he's a leader amongst our
ownership group yeah did AJ Green ever
lose his virginity what was that guy's
name
ac Green member that guy that was like
one of the big stories I remember as a
kid like AC green still staying a virgin
do you know if he ever lost his
virginity he was married I think so I'm
not sure I can't about true and I have
to ask his wife then probably your
ex-wife hopefully wife still do you uh
do you think there's like another piece
coming to the Lakers that we don't know
about kind of I think that you know
magics not gonna rest until we're proud
Wow so if how much would you love to
have Anthony Davis I have not I can't
talk about any player on any other team
well I'm a pelicans fan they told me
reason is like I'm not I'm not even
gonna acknowledge to your comment about
this Anthony Davis seems like a really
neat player
this past weekend is brought to you by
Skillshare Skillshare it's an online
learning platform with over 20,000
classes in business design technology
and more if you've been thinking about
taking a class you need to you need to
evolve in some area in order to get your
business sense where it needs to be to
move forward you can do that via
Skillshare you can take classes in
social media marketing data science
mobile photography creative writing you
name it they've got it so whatever
you're trying to deepen your
professional skill set you got to get
that skill set deep deep and you
can do that you want to start a side
hustle or if you just want to explore a
new passion Skillshare is there to keep
you learning and thriving join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners get two months of
Skillshare for just 99 cents that's
right
skills here is offering this past
weekend listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 20,000 classes
for just 99 cents to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo th EO again
go to Skillshare dot-com slash Theo to
start your two months right now that
Skillshare dot-com slashed Theo what
else do I want to think about ah so
let's get back to the comedy then do you
feel do you feel like you'll actually go
through with the class because I'm
having I have this feeling you're only
gonna take one the first class and not
finish the course why do you think that
I don't know why I just kind of got this
value it's it's it's really painful for
me it's really hard to get up in front
of a group of people when you get up
there in front of people what do you
think like wow here's my thing like
where are you supposed to look right do
you look out in the horizon and at no
one particular or do you like try to
make eye contact like well who do you
look at I think you look at people you
know yeah you look at people and you try
and look at like happy people that seem
like they're enjoying themselves and
then later for me I find anyway now I
look out and it's just this it's more of
like a performance sometimes right than
it is sometimes like a connection but
with the I would I don't like to give
advice but I would suggest a suggestion
what I would used to do what I would do
is try and connect you know try and
connect to somebody but see like that
like then I get thrown off if they're
like on their phone right doing
something in there you know and it has
nothing to do with me but then I get
rattled right you get rattled out of
your words yeah it's hard to remember
something and say at the same time but
with speeches and stuff what do you like
are like what kind of stuff you talking
about leadership that sort
thing like you giving a lot of like or
just like team updates like city
function that kind of stuff yeah I mean
you know I I think it's important you
know and I you know that's why I
hesitate to agree to speak but you know
they asked me to come to schools and I
think it's important for women to see a
woman in a position of power that is is
having success because I know that
inspired me yet what you know I looked
at at the role models and and you know
every everything about them how they
handled themselves what they stood for
you know how their how they ran their
lives you know and and the choices that
they made because you know there just
wasn't that many there weren't that many
women doing it right and so so um yeah
things have gotten so diverse now
it really has I mean I remember when I
was growing up there weren't I remember
you know like even growing up you didn't
see like a lot of black wealth when I
was young you know you saw like I mean I
remember thinking like the people on the
movie coming to America and and the
Dallas Cowboys like the only like
wealthy African Americans in America
kind of but now like you go to Atlanta
you go to some cities and there's a lot
of like african-american well there's a
lot of black wealth it's like things are
definitely changing you know I'm sure
has you guys fanbase you guys have so
many Latino fans you guys probably have
you guys in San Antonio just by sheer
location even have so many I get amazed
at how it because we have a lot of
Latino listeners like how many are like
like they love the Lakers they love the
Dodgers like it's just a sense of like
pride you know like a city pride have
you guys tried to get like more Latino
players but has that ever been like a
and I know there's not that many I mean
you know for us I mean we you know Pau
Gasol you know but you know he he was
European from Spain and but you know
could speak Spanish
Kobe speaks fluent Spanish so he speaks
Japanese students
it's like it's crazy I mean Italian
Spanish and you know could do full
interviews in another language hard that
is you know and and so I mean I think
we're we've always been represented well
and I don't think the fans care right
thing I'm just I think it would be neat
like I wonder if they maybe the fans
would even care about championing a guy
that's you know from you know that's you
know I think the point is is like we're
Laker fans first right like it isn't it
isn't it's like we want the best players
for our team we want a winning team yeah
and you know and everybody it doesn't
matter you know what language you speak
or you know where you're from it's it's
right it's like we are connected by our
love of the purple and gold yeah and
that's what I love about Laker fans
because we have the best fans in the NBA
in sports I think because they've been
patient and they've you know they have
they trust Magic Johnson to put together
a great team and they've been there for
us and and you know that's what that's
who we do the work for that's who we
want to be proud of their team yeah who
are is there a player over the years you
guys tried so hard to get in unit
weren't able to get I think you know you
know I don't want to like and they can
be retired now yeah it would it might
hurt some feelings okay that's all yeah
no worries
I respect that yeah I don't even
unfortunate son Abascal I started
getting more into it with the pelicans
whenever they got anything e Davis and
he's just been so exciting to watch and
then you know but we didn't have we had
like the Hornets and then they gave them
up and then they went to Oklahoma City
so it's been kind of a you know a little
bit of a rocky time did you ever did you
guys have Pistol Pete that played out
you know he didn't play but he played
for for New Orleans right and you know
now New Orleans that
owner who owned the the Saints and the
pelicans
yeah passed away and he left the teams
to his wife Gayle Gayle so now we have
another female owner and I couldn't be
more proud of her it's it's difficult
when you lose somebody that's so revered
and in a in a with a team in a market
like my dad was and she really this team
is something that's important to her and
and I admire her that's cool
do you have do you feel like she do you
feel a responsibility then as like a
female owner yeah yeah I mean I think
that you know I've been involved in so
many leagues going back to roller hockey
and all those you know indoor soccer and
arena football kind of prepping you for
this in a weird way did you realize that
at the time or you did it my dad did I
didn't I couldn't see past it but I
thought it was a punishment no but
certainly I know how your only is as
good in a league as you know your
weakest team and so you you have to do
things sometimes that maybe not be best
for your individual team but for the
health of the entire league because when
the league is healthy then the players
prosper and the team's prosper and and
truly we I think of any league we have
the best partnership between our players
that we acknowledge that how much how
important they are
they are the product right and that they
are partners in this and the Players
Association and stuff yeah a
relationship yeah and we have players
who can stand up for what they believe
in and you know we have the head of the
Players Association is Chris Paul and I
thought the way he you know when he was
with the Clippers and head of the Union
and that that situation he handled it so
well and you know I I think that you
know our league is is you know works
well with the Players Association which
is the head of the Association is
Michelle Roberts and so working with
her is you know she's the first woman to
ever run a male professional league
association exciting that's cool I'm
very proud do you feel like a lot of
people think like that there's the
league is too lopsided right now
do you worry about that yeah I mean I
think we're always concerned about all
the good players in California well I
mean you know I I think you know I think
what our league has proven is that you
don't have to be a major market to win a
championship and you know you you have
teams like San Antonio that you know can
win championships and then you have
Oklahoma City New Orleans was in the
playoffs the Lakers weren't last year so
that's a good point so it I think it's
the parity you know it isn't all you
know the Knicks haven't been in the
place for a long time as well so it
doesn't just automatically mean you know
big big big city you know playoff
success when so future dating so how are
you dating these days are you dating on
apps really I like I said I think I'm
gonna date my stalker people get upset
when I say stuff like that do you have a
certain type or no it's like I'm trying
to be funny people I know I mean you
know I I have no it just it's really it
it's it it's like I'm married to my job
how's that I'm married to that I haven't
have you
what is this belt here this I just got
voted like guest of the year for like a
podcast called fighter and the kid and
so I beat out like a bunch of like big
shots like really famous gotta fight to
get this I mean emotionally I did you
just had to go on their podcast and be
like the best guest so the fans voted me
like the best yes so yeah we all listen
to this it was cool yeah is pretty fun
and and those guys have a great podcast
called fighter and the kid
so well I I see this belt and it reminds
I I do have a passion project that I can
talk about it's the Wow women of
wrestling oh really
and so my partner was one of the
original founders of the gorgeous ladies
Wow right I used to probably just not
wear much and watch that you know when I
was young I said like that so we we're
starting our live matches in October
there and now it's women's wrestling and
it's women's wrestling and it's what I
love about it is that it's character
driven you know like we have good versus
evil yeah and and and you know the
performers are you gonna wrestle no I'm
not gonna wrestle but you know I I'm you
know I was in high school when title 9
was passed and title 9 opened up a lot
of opportunities for female athletes so
we have now this generation of great
female athletes who have earned
scholarships to perform at a collegiate
level in whatever sport field hockey
volleyball and there's not a lot of
places unless you're a basketball player
or tennis player figure skater for the
medal afterwards yeah they like earn a
living after years of dedicating to you
you know your athletic ability and
training and so I thought that it was
the right time to bring back the
gorgeous ladies of wrestling but now
under the name women of wrestling and
you know it's it's about female
empowerment it's about these great
performer athletes to have a chance to
earn a living
have you already chosen some of that
right yeah yeah we do I think one of my
my favorite wrestlers you know jungle
girl and she is she's as strong as any
person that I've ever really I've ever
watched we have a character Khloe Hertz
that after the Hertz rent-a-car company
no no it's like Hur T like she hurts
people yeah and she there's jungle girl
and
and then there's Chloe Hertz who there
she is all right yeah yeah
and so she likes to call herself that
all natural Wow
Oh a death yeah would she seem like a
nice girl yeah she is she's good and
it's fine it's fine it's it's a little
campy it's yes good but it's these girls
are unbelievable athletes and they
really deserve a platform right to shine
and I'm really excited I almost lost on
mine I was in the airport today's gonna
saw some own Augustus who was in the
WNBA and I saw I think Leslie Knowles
and both of them played at LSU I believe
I could be wrong about one him but they
had their whole team and their the whole
team sitting in and I was like I was
trying not to like mill around but
Simone played at LSU and so I'm just
such a big fan and it's also a bummer
living in Los Angeles cuz I'll see
purple and gold and I think it's for
Louisiana State oh right and that's
always for the Lakers so I'll be so
excited as a group you'll walk across
street I'm like you guys like Louisiana
and they're like no we like the Lakers
bro you both like LA yeah I had one
other question Nick you have calling
questions that came in yeah we have a
couple well I pull them up can you what
happened with like the Chris Paul trade
when that got blocked because it seemed
like it was because of competition but
like if you look at what go on States
doing like the OU brought up yeah I mean
I can give you an explanation if you
guys yeah from New Orleans right I was
up from the Clippers those from New
Orleans
we got him stolen and we got a guy who
seems like a nice man but also only has
one good leg onward I don't remember the
guys name he's a nice guy but he was
something happened to his leg right when
he got him well with with Chris Paul
what happened was the NBA was running
that team that the owner of the team at
the time turned it over to the league
and the league operated it from an arm's
length position and at that time we were
in a lockout with the the Union and all
the owners
we had we had made a deal with the Union
and the owners had all flown in to
ratify that agreement and so when all
the owners are in a room
you really can't accomplish a trade
because the owners are occupied with
this conversation this meeting that's
going on except my father didn't make
the trip because that was the beginning
of his illness and so he was back in LA
and the NBA was running the the New
Orleans team and so they had authorized
the general manager of that team to to
run the team without having to run
everything by the commissioner or
whatever it was like kind of an arm's
length thing so like a deal was the Dell
Demps or no it wasn't him yet yeah was
Dell Demps and so they made a deal and
it was in in the commissioner's opinion
not something that he would have
approved I say but it was it was kind of
like well you've given the authority for
him to make a deal and so it it kind of
it was just bad timing that's all and
and and had had it not been while
everybody because now the owners think
something's going on behind their back
because if the if if the if Chris Paul
was going to be traded they would all
want an opportunity to negotiate that
and they didn't get that opportunity
which made them feel like something not
right was going on and so I read it was
yeah so he vetoed it just to like calm
things down and then as soon as that
happened then we traded the players you
know Lamar Odom and and I forget who
else was in the trade so then to who to
Dallas oh yeah that's Lamar and so now
we broke up the assets that were trying
out the trades right so then we didn't
have it and so then then we didn't have
the P
says that we needed and they traded they
went ahead and traded them to the
Clippers yeah Eric Gordon that's his
luck didn't work yeah Eric Gordon yeah
nice guy but it was good for us that
this wasn't the same though and then we
lost Chris Paul and we had just made the
playoffs who made it to like the second
round we had David West a team was doing
pretty snazzy and then after that
everything fell apart I said Oh Leigh is
that a rings at a championship yeah I
would purposely wore it today did can I
wear it for a second it's like the girls
size one so you can't like the man ones
is like like a how big is napkin ring
yeah I don't wear really that looks good
on you actually that's a good let's
don't say that out loud it does it does
kind of married now I don't know it's
the first woman that ever put a ring on
me for sure maybe have you been married
I was married once to a volleyball
player really yeah it's a fun sport yeah
back in the late 80s early 90s
would you get married again you think um
I would like to get married again but I
just haven't been lucky you know it's
like it's hard it's hard I my career's
makes it really hard for me to be
available but does it actually at this
point does it make it hard for you to be
available or do you make more career so
that you're unavailable
you know I it's like it's difficult for
me to say because I write you know I had
one relationship after Phil that didn't
work out and you know I put a lot of
blame on just what I was dealing with in
you know my business and is it really
stressful with business is it it's it's
demanding yes you know and it's you have
to react in real time you can't say hey
it's the weekend don't bother me right
if there's a problem you have to be
available and who did you have and you
have a group obviously a board and stuff
you have magic you people we can go to
to work together to come up with ideas
and the next move yeah and you know it's
it's you know these these you know teams
are now worth you know in the
billions of dollars and they're there
they're worldwide known you know but you
know we've got like a hundred and twenty
employees you know we're a small company
but with this worldwide exposure and you
know we're the most you know popular
team in the world in terms of our
Facebook and really social media
following right which is is part of a
valuation of how you look at the value
of a company now do you miss some of the
old days when things seemed a little
smaller in some ways not in a bad way
but were there you know was there
something different about it it was
definitely you know you never knew I
mean back in when my dad first bought
the team you'd you know you didn't know
if a team was gonna miss an airplane
because they flew commercial right they
missed the airplane you might not have a
game that night what are you gonna do
and I mean just the kind of how far
we've come in terms of the
professionalism of putting on a game and
but I couldn't be more proud of our
Commissioner Adam Silver how he's been
at the forefront of so many important
decisions and now embracing the gaming
issue which for a long time was you know
kind of fear of teams in terms of you
know when gambling and stuff yeah you
know what that would mean to the
integrity of the game like the fantasy
aspect or not so much the fantasy
betting on the game yeah but in and you
know I mean we see a future where it's
going to be you know people gambling in
real time gaming you know on their
phones and and you know it just it makes
the outcome of game even that much more
interesting and and people more invested
and they already are and you know it's I
just I think it's it's just an evolving
thing it's going to happen it's been
it's happened in Europe already and it's
going to come here but you know Adam was
you know kind of on the forefront of
that and in instead of you know you know
fighting against the inevitable
he's you know talking about how the
right way to approach it the right way
to hold on to our integrity our
transparency so that people you know
they're there is no opportunity for
things to go offline yeah you know I've
romanticize a lot of things sometimes I
like do you know I just you I like to
sometimes in my mind I guess my heart
infects my mind too much in my thoughts
and memories even and I want to keep
just things a certain way you know and
it's hard sometimes just keeping moving
with the punches you know to just know
that things are going to change and
that's you can't hold on to a way that
you can remember it but you can't really
hold too close on to it because it's
things are going to change
that's very melancholy faster than ever
yeah is it it makes me a little sad does
it yeah I'm thinking of like you know
you down in the Bayou and like you know
like the fireflies oh no wait that's a
ride at Disneyland wait yeah what ride
is that is that Friar's is that a Brer
Rabbit you know when you go have you
ever been to that restaurant where it's
like near the Pirates of the Caribbean
and like it's oh you have to go
sometimes a secret place
really oh yeah it's regular people don't
get invited today you'll have to take me
over there I would go Jeanie buss thank
you so much let's get to a couple of
calls right that came in Hey headphones
see if I maybe just turn it up and you
can hear from the headphone
oh we just put them on as our or that's
fine yeah you can just whatever works
yeah those are a little bit alarming
okay go ahead hey Co this is Joey from
Ventura so a couple weeks back in Oxnard
killed it man a question for genie from
Lakers nation when you posed for Playboy
who what did dr. buss think of that
anyway I loved the show feel young again
Wow and we can hit we believe we'll
leave them on for this part okay um
yeah I haven't seen too much can we
bring these images up or this can be
really awkward
no you come yeah let's bring a mug bro I
mean this seems like an a professional
it seemed like yeah and this could this
is gonna be part of my comedy looks
you'd like I can you know give you some
nice is perfect but you know actually
when I'm up in high def if you don't
mind brother see what they had and you
know I talked about challenging myself
to you know above you know do things
that are jeannie bugs my comfort zone
and this was definitely one of those
things it was after my first marriage
ended and I decided okay what are some
of the things that I would do if I was
single and this was and so I went to I
had to I was like any other model who
was in the magazine I had to go to a
test photo shoot never told my dad about
it I went through all the you know test
photos and so was a little disconcerting
to see the pictures as I'm talking about
and click through him a little bit Nick
if you don't mind so I can listen and
think at the same time yeah so I was
approved did the photo shoot then I told
my dad that it was coming out and my dad
so brilliant had the the greatest quote
ever which was it will be the first
issue of Playboy magazine I've never
read Wow so he he endorses the magazine
but he you know if it says don endorses
his daughter everything his daughter
knew right and so you know and you know
I didn't know I didn't read playboy
alright you know and I didn't really
realize like how hair styles you know
hair styles change and hairstyles change
oh yeah kind of Jeannie bush a little
yeah but it's also kind of the times I
remember some of these magazines and
stuff and you would see in the Ted just
had more of a natural kind of vibe to it
but so they didn't like did they tell
you you have to shave or anything no
they didn't tell me anything they you
know it was it was I thought like you
know I would I would you know the first
time that I would you take us oh so
nervous
us and I thought it was like this is
just gonna be like oh my god and like
nobody cared they're like doing their
work they're like fixing the light you
know and then there's a guy crying on
the phone who his wife just normal
activity right just it was like what the
only person who was hung up on it was
meet you
who'd you take with you to the shoot
really yeah at what age is this at
Jeannie I was 32 when I did it Wow
and so what kind of 30 Tirol just drop
just you know what's on my to-do list
today I have to hit the grocery I have
to check on a say see greens virginity
whoa Google Image Search no I you know
it's funny because when when the Lakers
Christ went to the the White House when
Obama was president and you know I we
all got to meet him in the green room
before we went out to do the
presentation and so I introduced myself
to him and he said I know who you are
and I felt so like self-conscious like
he'd seen me in place do you think
indeed is that the vibe you got the
colors that it was it's okay he's the
president deserves a look at play well
why and I do I have you know I have you
know people now that come up to me and
they said that you were the first naked
person I've ever seen you know and and
you know now mind you I did this in the
early 90s before the internet really was
right so yeah pictures are with me
forever and you know I so going back do
you think you would have kind of had a
different hairstyle you think or it
doesn't matter really yeah yeah I would
have been more like race racing strip or
whatever yeah something fancy clown ears
or some Disney ears when you look at
these pictures is it just kind of like
oh do you remember the day pretty fun
like was it just one day was it a couple
no it was the hardest work I've ever
done where I was so physically tired but
mentally completely not stimulated at
all like really like I it like
you have to like stay put with an arch
in your back and you know yeah do not
move and it was I all my all the power
two models in the world because they
don't get enough credit for the kind of
physicality that is to pose do you feel
sexy looking at these pictures is it
feeling like that um you know not yeah
kinda but I mean not at that time
because it's you're you're working was
your city did you have any siblings that
were jealous to give us it was your
sister there were no jealousy like that
no sister jealousy no I mean me doing
this didn't preclude anybody else from
doing anything they would want to do
that's a good point you would you do it
again you know I'm really good friends
with Cooper Hefner Hugh Hefner son and
you know they he's you know taking the
magazine in a different direction I'm so
proud of him at his young age he's
really shown the kind of thoughtfulness
and you know really you know really
wants the magazine to stand for
something important and everybody should
follow him on Instagram because he's
really he's a really special kid and of
this generation that generation and so I
don't think they would ask me again but
if they ask do you think it was ID by an
issue to sold one issue Wow and it could
have borrowed mine but let's he be
honest he wants his own what reasons who
knows but obviously does want to borrow
his buddies so that's two issues there
we go Cooper so what do you think so
you're saying there's a chance
anything else Nick give any question no
yeah I got mine out um Jeanie buss
thanks so much I want to uh yeah I might
have to buy a Jersey okay well I think
I'd rather you come to my showcase all
right do you stand up can I don't know
can over they come would you let me go
really why wouldn't you well you did
you think I'm gonna quit after tonight
so we'll see we'll see if I make it yeah
there we go
do you have one quick question um Lavar
balls been in the news list did you guys
like get him to shut up or is the media
just sick of them yeah Lavar ball gag is
being sold on the Internet somebody's
been selling a Lavar ball gag but I
think Lavar balls also kind of exciting
and I think he's almost a sign of future
dads to come do you in a weird way you
know I admire his devotion to his
children and I think that a father who
cares about his kids and and advocates
for his kids is really important yeah is
it hard sometimes because you answer
like all your answers are super pristine
sometimes like is it hard sometimes to
go through that filter a little bit I
mean I don't think you see I don't think
you seem programmed right I'm not saying
that right right right but is it hard
does it feel like sometimes like you
have to because you're a businesswoman
you were running a huge business you're
part of something you know that is
represents a lot of people right so you
have to we have to have a filter right I
you know everything I everything
everything has to be constructive that I
don't believe in being critical without
having how can it be different you know
if you're if you're willing to criticize
somebody for how they do something right
because you're bad virtus ism you better
know what way they had a choice of like
you give you you fix it you talk about
it instead of just saying negative a
person's bad right
yeah we need solution there's not enough
solution sometimes you know there's not
enough solution I find these days is
there's so much judgment and not enough
solution and also not enough
understanding of where people come from
mm-hmm you know people are like America
is very different country you know we're
just different in a lot of places you
know people come from different places
did did Trump ever come to any games I'm
sure he did over the years huh yeah I
mean you know so did Clinton Bill
Clinton I mean we've had all the
different presidents what about Michael
Landon did he ever come Michael Landon
yeah I love Michael Landon me too yeah I
mean I love him to death I was such a
huge Michael angel is he like your
substitute dad I think he was I think
for a lot of Americans he wasn't
especially for me you know as a young
man I think yeah it was like that was
almost the only time that my siblings
and I even had like a family it felt
like was when every wait Michael and
little house and then highway to heaven
I'm Victor French I loved both of those
guys no Bonanza uh-uh
I mean I would go back and watch as I
was about almost one you want to see him
like that he was just too much of a
rogue youngster I need more that father
figure you know but I think yeah watch
I've read I read all the books I was a
huge I was a huge little house fan and I
met Nellie Oleson one time at the Chase
Bank Wow
did you tell her that how much yeah I
told her yeah yeah and I also met Althea
from in the heat of the night which is
another one of my favorite TV shows with
Carroll O'Connor did he ever come to a
game not that I am aware of I can't say
that Rodney Dangerfield um you know
Peter Falk used to come on did he really
he's buried at Westwood Cemetery and
Walter Matthau he's buried at Westwood
Cemetery jeepers
yeah how many freakin former Lakers uh
fans are buried her Westwood Cemetery
that's crazy that's awesome yeah my dad
always had this thing that you know if
if you had a friend visiting from out of
the state out of the country and they
said I'm gonna come to LA and I want to
see three things I want to go to
Disneyland I wanna go to the beach and I
want to see a real live celebrity where
would you take them to see a real-life
celebrity live yet would have been
Westwood cemetery feudin put live in
there but I guess now would be the
Lakers game right yeah that's true every
night that you know you're gonna see a
celebrity yeah it's like that's true
excellent well maybe we'll be there one
day
Jeanne boss thank you so much for
joining us and uh and and we wish you
the best of luck this year and you end
the whole Lakers nation thank you for
the support
yeah I appreciate it and I want to come
laughs soon and I'll help you right
anytime you want you've already heard my
best well I've definitely seen some of
your best work let me pull those up
[Music]
little town for me to slap that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]